okay so so now let now we're going to
apply this same exercise that we just
did so so here what we did we showed
that there is no fundamental difference
between language change in English
versus then languages in the history of
Asian Creole right because what we're
doing here we're we're questioning this
notion that Creole formation is
something which is very interesting
critique which separates Creoles from
non Creoles in a fundamental sense now
now what we need to do when to look at
the history of French itself from Latin
I'm going to ask
so does that history is it supposed to
be can it be in any way compared to what
having the history of Creole in fact
what we're going to see is that if you
compare Latin and French in many ways
they show that French also out
creolization Creole right so we're just
going to do it very in fact it is what
I'm going to do now is wait and then
choose okay but I'm warning you that
it's and then choose because invest what
I'm doing that when I'm comparing French
and Latin is exactly what other
linguists do in the compare say Haitian
Creole to all the languages they pick a
small set of patterns and they say well
look this set of patterns make really
special so now I am picking this set of
patterns actually which are very
fundamental to the grammar of any
language right which is the order of
words so and this is so scrambling is a
technical term so if that means that any
of you know German who knows German you
know German okay so okay you can so so
German has it has this property that you
can pronounce so if you see you know say
I don't know Mary loves pancakes right
you can move things around you can see
pancakes rosemary right right yeah but
the arguments can move around so the
verb is is is as a strict position but
then arguments a move around
it can come first and Latin is of the
same nature any of us still Latin if you
know that
okay okay so many languages have this
capacity call that's a simple case of
language like at MIT we'd call it
scrambling right
insects scramble egg you can scramble
things around so you can have a sentence
you have the subject within the object
and if you have other things like I
don't know the object if you say like
John gave a book to Mary you have three
roles in that sentence know the giver
what's been given what we see what's
being given and things can move around
in the sentence we can be scrambled now
Latin has that you can scramble things
around not French so cases is like in
Latin right when you say you know girl
it's like we laugh we loom freely right
you get you you indicate like in German
exactly so exactly exactly so those two
things are connected good point good for
Jonathan so so in in in Latin you have
these endings that are called
case kids detentions that tell you
whether the the noun is a subject is an
object and and with that you can move
things around more easily now notice
that you have it in Latin and in French
you don't so in French like in English
you only have kiss smacking like on
pronouns like he versus him versus his
okay you have that on pronouns but you
don't have some nouns you don't have the
equivalent of he he him he him his you
don't have that one announced right but
in Latin any noun will have to carry an
ending that tells you is it a subject is
an object that it's called case so you
have overt case okay in Latin you don't
have articles like that you know so if
you learn Latin you have to learn that
you don't have it the in French of it so
these are four basic properties that you
find in Latin that you don't find in
French right so so the point is that
well look you know along these four
major parameters French is very
different from Latin which so if one
were to take the kind of words that are
used to describe Creole you
see well French has broken Latin grammar
French is broken Latin right that's what
you have to say right because we have
four basic properties of of Latin that
somehow friends because I've lost as
they learn to speak Latin and create in
French now guess what if we take those
very same properties and we compare
French and Haitian Creole they are the
same no canonical order both languages
exist
well we saw that for pronouns we don't
have we have very different for pronouns
but for full nouns you have the same
verb of the order scrambling French and
Creole we have the same overt case the
same article the same right so what is
that show that at least along these four
parameters in Creole is much better
behaved than French you know so in fact
so if you were to if you were to create
a degree of coolness based on how broken
the grammar is which is often what
language well they people do often they
think of Creole as Jamaican Creole in
spoken English French Haitian Creole is
broken French so here you'd have to say
then that French is broken Latin and
actually this is the day's a very
well-known historical linguists go on 20
million and 20 media was aware of that
and when me actually wrote something
which I find very striking he said that
you know if we compare the Romance
languages so not only French but Spanish
Italian Portuguese Romanian you know so
they are called the Romance languages
actually I often hear people say the
romantic languages we can be romantic
but the technical the technical term is
there remains remains languages ok so so
those Romance language is the a
structures that are actually use the
term fundamentally different from the
Latin counterparts okay so so linguist
very smart language aware of that and
even say that this is still me
all this makes you call it neo Latin
languages fall into it the logical class
that is quite remote from the social
type
flatten and let's make clear right
that's couldn't be any clearer right so
which means that this notion of of
Creole languages having broken the
syntax of the European ancestors is
inflate intentions because it's second
language realized that all languages
evolved by through these structural
breaks even those that are often
presented as prototypical genetic
lineages being that nemesis with parents
so I think we're like the we're like the
college languages did they have those
like features a good question yeah I
don't know about domination that's what
you were to find out so how did French
develop those patterns is it from the
substrate language is like the college
that's a very good question yeah that's
exactly what you would want to ask
because we know and in the case of
Haitian Creole not all and I wanna
stress not all but many of the other
features efficient Creole were inherited
from the African substrates like for
example the fact that you have the
article after the now not be further
down that streets out from the be
linkages which have the same pattern
right so so so the point here so there's
a common thread here in the argument
right that those breaks that you see in
the history of colleges you also find
them in the history of non crew
languages so there was one name is
sometime ago called African secure
language you get into big trouble
because the Africans because were you
upset that's right exactly tenants were
upset that they they are compared the
African language to do Korea because for
them you know African was just with
righty of Dutch and it should not be
never colloquial that was in the early
80s I think early 80s but it was a very
live discussion in fact and at some
point there was an English word to step
back with you okay
Africa
is Ana creo if you see my creo you know
and then so what I have to add that
linguist actually is chan-hom late John
home and I asked so how do you measure
see my cruelness
so how many features must you have to be
a semi Creole right so which goes back
to that question we can you define
coolness based on instead of features
which is very problematic machine